bueno el fin del aislamiento de maduro
es algo que se viene discutiendo desde
que líderes de izquierdas se usaron en
varios países de América Latina pero hoy
fue el mismo Lula quien dijo que con
este evento se da el inicio del regreso
de maduro realmente se ve así
Sí desde 2019 el gobierno venezolano
está buscando reinsertarse en la región
durante estos últimos años maduro ha
viajado a Turquía ha viajado a Qatar ha
hecho lo posible por estar presente pero
digamos en Suramérica tenía las cosas
muy difíciles con la alineación
ideológica de muchos gobiernos muchos
los cuales son críticos sigue habiendo
gobiernos críticos a maduro en la
subregión pero ahora tenemos un gobierno
muy importante como el de Brasil que le
está abriendo las puertas y lo está
invitando a este evento
ahora el regreso de maduro a la escena
regional e internacional se puede
considerar un fracaso de la política de
Estados Unidos ante el gobierno chavista
o simplemente un cambio de rumbo por
convivencia ante el contexto
internacional
creo que va mucho más allá la capacidad
de la política estadounidense puesto que
no pueden controlar Quién es el lector
en los países de Suramérica y bueno el
desgaste que generó el tiempo eso
siempre fue una cuestión muy importante
para analizar la crisis venezolana el
tiempo que pasó desde que Juan guaidó
ascendió como presidente interino se
sabía que mientras más tiempo pasa la
segunda transición
más era la posibilidad de que se
normalizaran las relaciones de Venezuela
con el resto de la región
Bueno finalmente la forma en la que está
configurada hoy Suramérica tal vez
ayudará a que se pueda lograr ese
proyecto de revivir la unasur como lo
presenta el presidente Luis Ignacio Lola
da Silva
es posible Aunque lo interesante sería
superar tanto prosur como unasur porque
ya
surgió como una alternativa unasur
oponiéndose a la ideología que le trató
de insertar a un azul Chávez kirchner y
Lula en su momento Entonces quizás haya
que relanzar el mecanismo de alguna
manera con otro nombre y con un objetivo
mucho más amplios fuera de matices
ideológicos